I'm looking forward to y'all getting a
treatment I'm looking forward to you
getting a recovery
I'm looking forward to taking them steps
everybody not gonna go at the same time
that's the time to program and celebrate
its individual lives but starch knows
it's no easy task to turn these women
around the drugs are bad enough but
there's another lure the drama in danger
of the streets it's the rush the streets
are in my blood I live for the streets I
know that I can go out for example right
before New Year's ago I made five
hundred dollars in less than ten minutes
okay
that right there is a rush she likes the
street life she says that a lot it's not
so much as the drugs miss starts it's
just a lifestyle or whatever and I still
think that way but I know reality I'm
gonna end up dead I've gone through the
jails
the institution the next is death for me
and I'm not ready
Michelle needs to get our act together
in a few days she'll have to convince
judge Lloyd to let her stay in Fresh
Start I'm facing a two-year program in
front of a judge I got my record is huh
very plentiful and colorful but you know
what that's me
you know there's a time for change I'm
gonna give it a try
to make it in the program Michelle is
counting on Nikki her girlfriend on the
outside
she's Michelle's lifeline in jail
keeping in touch with letters and
sending her money and Michelle more and
more counsel and starts for help but
Starks has more than Michelle Bailey to
worry about
she has over 70 women to watch over and
sometimes gets calls for help in the
middle of the night but she gets other
calls to call she dreads about women who
have been lost forever this is the last
stop for missing persons the county
morgue a Jane Doe has just been brought
in and Starks needs to find out if she's
one of her Fresh Start runaways I know
you guys have some Jane dolls here I was
coming to see if you could verify if any
of these ladies are could be possibly
could be any of the Jane Doe that you
have they've been missing for a couple
of months almost a year we have one
young lady that has a tattoo of a rolls
on our body that any of these have
tattoos and rolls which one won't that
be the corpse is so deteriorated that
it's almost impossible to match but
Starks has found fresh start women in
the morgue before the woman that I found
she stuck with the lifestyle the street
life and the streets devoured her pretty
much you know it's never good news
coming down here if I find a match